hello everybody um today we are back for
episode seven which means that this
channel has now been around for a full
week and i have yet to lose my job that
is absolutely huge uh if you're new here
please um click the subscribe button i
don't actually care if you unsubscribe
later i just kind of want to hit that
100 number so i can um you know get
naked for the camera and then you know
unsubscribe will go back below who cares
but uh yeah let's talk about weak
isolation levels because this is kind of
the last thing that i wanted to cover
before doing like a full on
uh straight up database comparison um
between like a bunch of the popular
technologies so okay i'll get into the
powerpoint okay so today's video is on
weak isolation levels
if you recall from last video's content
the point of transactions is that
they're a really useful abstraction
however the trade-off of using them is
that they're really slow because
databases have to actually implement
serializable isolation instead what many
databases will choose to do instead is
throw out serializable isolation and
instead offer weaker guarantees about
transaction isolation so we're in order
to kind of present this we're going to
go through a bunch of concurrency bugs
and look at the strategies that
databases use in order to mitigate them
without providing complete isolation
okay so there are five types of
concurrency bugs that we're going to
talk about dirty reads dirty rights read
sku lost updates and then right sku in
conjunction with phantoms
what are dirty reads well this is
basically just saying that if data has
been written by a transaction but it
hasn't yet committed let's say a
transaction has to make multiple rights
and one of the rights has been done but
the other hasn't so it's not committed
yet
um any rights that have not been
committed should not be read by a
different transaction it's pretty simple
how do we actually go about solving this
well it's pretty
easy to do the database just make sure
to remember the old value of a write
until it's completed and this way you
don't have to use locks because that
would take a huge performance hit on the
system
so let's say we're editing the key kim's
man used to be kanye
we're now going to update it to pete but
until that transaction is completed
we're going to store both values
and then finally once the transaction is
complete we just store pete and that way
that
if any transaction tries to read from
that it'll see kanye until the right is
completely committed or aborted
okay dirty writes when writing data
we're not going to overwrite
uh
non-committed data so we can only
overwrite committed data how do we solve
this well for every single object we
just put a lock on it and you can only
have one writer thread operating on that
at a time so
if that right has not yet been committed
the transaction that made the right is
still holding the lock and the second it
commits or aborts the transaction
releases the lock
okay now let's talk about read committed
isolation so the whole point of read
committed isolation is this is going to
be the weakest isolation level because
all it does is actually go ahead and
solve those dirty reads and dirty writes
but it's pretty easy to implement and it
doesn't take too big of a performance
hit at all which is why it can be useful
okay the next concurrency bug we're
going to talk about is read sku
read sku is basically saying let's
imagine we have a long read query that's
going to read a bunch of rows or objects
from the database
but while that query is actually reading
what it's going to see is that multiple
rows are changing since it's a super
long query in fact some of the rows are
going to be changing even while the read
is happening so it might actually
observe the database in an inconsistent
state
so the solution here is snapshot
isolation which i'll explain in a moment
but to to summarize read skew even more
let's imagine i'm venmo okay and i want
to sum up the total balances of all the
accounts in my system
so i start running this huge query which
is going to go through all of the rows
of the users and add up their balances
so let's say now i'm in
venmo with my hundred dollar account and
my friend also has a hundred dollars in
venmo but while this long read analytics
query is running my friend transfers me
fifty dollars however before he
transfers me the fifty dollars the
analytics query reads the balance of my
account so the analytics query thinks
that i have a hundred dollars in my
account and then since he's transferred
me fifty dollars and then the analytics
query reads his account it thinks that
he has fifty dollars in his account so
the total value of both accounts is now
messed up it should be two hundred
dollars but they think it's only a
hundred
so this is where snapshot isolation
comes in
so what is snapshot isolation well it's
basically this every transaction is
assigned a monotonically increasing
transaction id which just means that
every single transaction has an id one
higher than the previous one so when
writing a value what the database is
actually going to do is store all of
those previous values of that key
and store it with the transaction id so
as you can see below i have for the key
jordan cute with the transaction id of
one because that means transaction one
wrote that handsome with a transaction
id of eight and brolic with a
transaction id of 14. same thing goes
for bieber who at one point was gross
has since been updated to uglier than
jordan and finally okay fine he's good
looking
however
let's say transaction 15 wants to read
the values for both jordan and bieber
while it's currently the case that the
database has those values
most updated being brolic and okay fine
good looking transaction 15 is not
actually allowed to see the okay find
good looking because 15 is less than 19.
instead transaction 15 must take the
most up-to-date value that is basically
less than or equal to it so transaction
15 can see brolic at 14 but not okay
fine good looking at 19. so instead we
would read brolic and uglier than jordan
let's note though that if snapchat
isolation were not a thing then
transaction 15 might end up reading
brolic and okay fine good looking simply
by the fact that it's possible that
transaction 15 would have read the value
for jordan and then transaction 16 would
have committed for bieber and then
finally 15 would have gone and read that
and then it would have been a different
value
so keep in mind that that's the race
condition that snapshot isolation is
going to be preventing
okay next we've got lost updates
so basically there's something called a
read modify write cycle that we see
happening a lot in databases where we
want to read some value modify it by a
certain amount and then write it back to
the database
so for example let's say my net worth is
a million dollars in reality it's about
you know 100 times that but let's not
worry about that we've got two
transactions both of which are going to
read my net worth and add another
million dollars to it because this
youtube channel has been going crazy
okay so with this in mind both of those
reads are going to see that i have a
million dollars in my account and then
they're going to add another million
both of which now think that i have two
million dollars
now they're both going to write and it
seems like i only have two million
dollars when in reality i've been conned
out of a million so there are three
possible solutions for this and i'll
discuss all three of them those are
atomic write operations explicit locking
or automatic database detection
okay atomic write operations a lot of
databases actually have built-in
atomic counters or operations like
compare and set that allow you to um you
know do something like an increment
without actually having to worry about
concurrency issues however not all of
them do or perhaps we're doing something
else like i don't know appending to a
string or something and in that case you
may actually have to use explicit blocks
in your application code
keep in mind though that explicit
locking in application code is kind of
annoying as a developer and you
obviously don't want to have a bug in
there because you know keeping a lock
and never releasing it for example can
really do a number on your database
so instead whenever possible it's better
to use automatic database detection
this is basically when the database says
okay i can see that the premise of one
of these read modify write cycles has
changed and as a result of it changing
we know that one of these transactions
is going to be invalid we have to retry
it how can we do that well it's really
easy in conjunction with snapshot
isolation because of the fact that you
can actually see what a given
transaction read and then you know that
that's changed right before it writes
back so again this is good because
it reduces the opportunities of us as
developers to write bad code
the thing though is that in multi-leader
leaderless replication these techniques
don't work for example let's say
you know i want to add a million dollars
to my account and then
you know my business partner in china
also wants to add a million dollars to
my account so we both are going to
attempt to
add that counter however my counter
doesn't even exist in the chinese
version of the database and as a result
this is all moot so basically the the
point there is is that something like an
atomic write operation doesn't exactly
work in setups where there are multiple
possible leaders and as a result that's
where we would use something like
conflict resolution
where you know we store them as siblings
or something like a crdt which i briefly
touched on in the multi-leader
replication video
okay next let's talk about right sku so
two transactions are going to read the
same set of objects in order to make
basically a predicate
and they're going to use that predicate
in order to make a subsequent decision
which is reflected as a right however
because of the fact that these two
transactions are going to change
different members of the table
those members are not necessarily going
to be locked so what do we have to do we
have to go ahead and lock every single
thing in that predicate so for example
let's say this is a table right here i'm
at the club and as you can see i'm
currently sitting at a table with
lindsay lohan and the tables only have
capacity for three so it's important
that only three people can be sitting at
table one
so what's going to happen
one transaction is going to see two
people at table one and another
transaction is going to also see two
people at table one and they're both
going to update their row to join my
table
obviously this is what breaks the
invariant i said there are only three
people to a table and the only way to
actually solve this problem is to make
sure that we can go ahead and lock all
of the rows originally of people on
table one so that that way uh only one
transaction can read those at a time
so like i said this is called a
predicate lock you're literally just
putting a a lock on all those rows and
that way
only one transaction can read them
however a problem that comes up here is
what if those rows don't all exist yet
so going back what if for example
kdoptin and megan fox weren't actually
in the table yet because they hadn't
joined the club and weren't standing
around at no table
well this is called a phantom it's the
same issue as right sku but the problem
here is that the invariants are broken
when both transactions create a new row
because there is actually nothing to put
a lock on
so the solution here would actually be
to materialize conflicts so let's
discuss that
imagine i want to book a meeting in a
given room at some given time
first i would query the database to see
if there's a row in the bookings table
that already corresponds to that room in
that time then if it's not there i would
actually go ahead and add my meeting
slot as a new row to the bookings table
however let's imagine it's not there if
it's not i can't apply a predicate lock
to that condition because of the fact
that there's no row in the database so
we actually have to do is create a dummy
row in our bookings table let's say
every single meeting for a given week
we're going to use like a scheduled job
or a cron job
to create all those dummy rows for a
given week and then that way i can put a
lock on that and then claim the room for
myself this is called materializing
conflicts because we're actually
purposely materializing some row that we
can have transactions conflict on via
grabbing that lock so i would actually
create an empty row go ahead and lock it
and then that way we could assure
isolation there
okay so i know this was a little bit to
digest but it's not overly complicated
at the end of the day so to summarize it
read committed isolation is going to
prevent dirty reads and dirty writes
snapshot isolation is going to prevent
read skew which is more or less when you
see that database in an inconsistent
state amongst rows and it can be easily
adapted to detect those lost updates
which is really good because then the
developer doesn't have to deal with
explicit locking
finally predicate locks and
materializing conflicts can be used to
prevent right skew and phantoms which is
when you read a bunch of rows in a query
use that as your predicate and either
change an existing row or write a new
row
okay so basically when should we use
these weak isolation levels well like i
said oftentimes it's the case that
databases can't actually handle the
performance impact that it takes to use
actual serializable isolation
however it is the case as well that when
you are able to handle that load
perhaps you should just use serializable
isolation because it's a lot simpler to
think about and you don't have to reason
about the other concurrency bugs that
your weak isolation levels may have
missed
all right guys i hope you enjoyed this
one i'm going to be doing probably a
pretty dense video next time to do a bit
of a database comparison but uh yeah
i'll see you then